the great Jackie Chan  let me tell you my story working with a  living legend was amazing every day I  couldn't wait to come on the set to see  Jackie Chan I was late most of the time  but when I got there  Jackie was there waiting with his legs  crossed and where's Chris Tucker we are  late you know but he didn't complain you  know he knew I was this young kid  who didn't know his lines but he went  with the flow  working with Jackie got me Global  notoriety too from the rush hour movies  you might have seen automatically  working with a global star like Jackie  Chan Jackie I love you you're part of me  I thank you  and I'm so thrilled and honored to be a  part of this to present you my good  friend Jackie Chan with the honorary  Oscar ladies and gentlemen give it up  for Jackie Chan